as well as our immediate priority to
invest record something the NHS to cut
waiting lists I want to make sure that
the NHS is fit for the future and
today's announcement expansion of lung
cancer screening is a good example of
that lung cancer is the leading cause of
death by cancer in the UK and we know
that if you catch it early then you can
much more improve the chance of people
surviving it the pilot schemes that
we've been running people will have seen
land trucks and Supermarket car Parks
like the one we're in today make an
enormous difference and that's why we
will roll it out nationally targeting
those adults at risk and in doing so
save thousands of people's lives it's a
good example of doing the right thing
for the long-term benefit of the NHS and
for patients everywhere but frankly the
NHS is not in a good State there's a
king's fund report out today which says
effectively that you know our outcomes
amongst comparable countries is not
great we're 16th and 18th in terms of
preventable and treatable
countries in terms of care and mortality
rates it's not a great record you've
been in power for 13 years now the NHS
seems to go in the wrong direction
well one of my five priorities is to cut
NHS waiting lists that's why we've put
record sums into the NHS since I became
prime minister with record numbers of
doctors nurses and new ways of doing
things which are starting to make a
difference and we're seeing that in the
numbers but of course there's work to do
but we also need to make the decisions
that will modernize the NHS for the long
term today's example rolling out lung
cancer screening will really help
improve survival rates for lung cancer
something where we are behind other
countries but today's announcement will
help fix that but also later this week
we'll be making a really important
announcement for the first time in its
history the NHS will have a long-term
Workforce plan to make sure that we hire
the doctors the nurses and all the other
GPS and medical staff that we need for
the long term reduce our Reliance on
foreign trained clinical staff those are
the right long-term decisions for the
NHS and that's what I'm interested in
doing talk about that I've got friends
who are doctors and nurses who are
moving to Australia and Canada the
leaving the national anthem service
trained here why are they doing that
because they're getting paid more why
are you not prepared to pay Junior
doctors and other NHS staff more
I think everyone can see the economic
context that we're in with inflation
higher than we'd like it and it's
important that in that context the
government makes the right and
responsible decisions on things like
public sector pay I'm actually very
pleased that over a million NHS workers
represented by half a dozen unions
accepted the government's payoffer and
I'm very grateful to them for that and
for the incredible work they're doing
it's very disappointing that the junior
doctors have taken the decision that
they have done over half a million
people's treatments have already been
disrupted I don't think anyone wants to
see that carry on it's just going to
make it harder to bring waiting lists
down and I think people need to
recognize the economic context we're in
and I'm going to make the decisions that
are the right ones for the country
that's not always easy people may not
like that but those are the right things
for everybody that we get a grip of
inflation and that means the government
not excessively borrowing too much money
and being responsible with public sector
pay settlements that's what I'm going to
do and I would urge everyone to see that
that's the right course of action just
before I get on to other subjects just
on that specifically because the unions
through this are you saying the public
sector pay is a major driver of
inflation they say it's not or
government borrowing is something that
would make inflation worse so the
government has to make priorities and
decisions about where best to Target our
resources and that's why when it comes
to public sector pay we need to be fair
but we need to be responsible as well
and we've done that we've reached
agreement with over half a dozen NHS
unions representing over a million
workers who accepted the government's
offer and I'm very grateful to them for
that the junior doctors are asking for I
think a 35 pay increase I think everyone
can see that that's completely
unreasonable given the context we're in
and it's important that we bring
inflation down over half a million
people's treatments have already been
disrupted that's not something I want to
see continue I want to see us getting
the waiting list down we're already
investing record sums in the NHS so no
one can say that we're not putting the
money in but it's important that we
don't make the inflation situation worse
and it's important we prioritize the
things that are right that's why later
this week we'll be making an
announcement that expands a number of
doctors nurses GPS that we train that
those are the right things to do I'm
making the decisions that are right for
the long term and that's what I'm going
to continue doing